contrastive learning is a beautiful idea
it asks the simple question are two
signals the same or different it can be
used to distinguish between similar and
dissimilar things and the key idea is
that distinguishing is more important
than complete reconstruction I want to
tell you a little secret unsupervised
learning specifically self supervised
learning is going to be the next big
thing oh no wait a minute
I tell a lie it's already the biggest
game in town why tell the machines what
to learn doing so limits their
representational capacity and it also
stops them from learning global and
local features we can learn much better
representations of social supervision
because there's almost no limit to the
amount of data that we can generate
there's quite a few things that we're
talking about here other than
reinforcement learning there's this
concept of contrastive learning transfer
learning data augmentation and self
supervision the first time I came across
contrasted learning was the skip gram
model by Michelob in 2013 the first
version of his algorithm had a soft max
output space or a hierarchical soft max
output space with across the entire
vocabulary what he was trying to do was
to predict the next word in in a
sequence of words but the really clever
trick that he did to improve the
computational performance of his
algorithm was to do this contrasted
output with a negative sampling so a
positive sample would be two words that
are in the context of each other and a
negative sample would be a word in some
other random word from the corpus and
then this is a self supervision task so
you can just generate you know lots and
lots of pairs of words and you can learn
an internal representation which will
project words into a geometric space
where words that are often in the
context of each other would be you know
geometrically similar so all of the
first names would be am close to each
other
of course then we get into the transfer
learning thing because these embeddings
that you've pre trained on a self
supervision task could be used for
downstream tasks it's reasonably easy to
come up with a self supervised task for
language processing but how do we do the
same thing for computer vision similar
thing here where there was a contrast of
loss for learning image it beddings was
the face net paper and that used a
triplet loss which has an anchor of
positive and a negative and it has a
margin as well and you could make the
algorithm converge faster by having a
mining strategy which would select an
anchor and a positive which were as
dissimilar as possible so the algorithm
was was learning but that still needed
annotations you still needed to know
whether or not the person was the same
person well I first became aware of this
in in about June of last year when I
interviewed Devon young for his deep
info max paper and he was using data
augmentations in computer vision as
Excel supervision tasks so we have sims
CLR and we have moco which we'll talk
about today and essentially what they do
is they they take a whole bunch of
different augmentations so let's just
say cutouts for the time being and the
self supervision task is to ask the
algorithm do these cutouts belong in the
same image and what fascinates me about
this so much is that you can actually
learn even better representations from
unsupervised approaches than you can
from supervisor approaches the paper
we're going to talk about today is curl
contrastive unsupervised representations
for reinforcement learning by Srinivas
it out Cole took cebause date of the art
performance on playing Atari games using
reinforcement learning and you might
recall this from the deepmind paper so
the setup is very similar you use four
frames from an Atari game and you train
a reinforcement learning algorithm just
using the pixels what's different though
in in this paper is Srinivas is really
interested in sample efficiency rather
than looking for that asymptotic you
know performance at about a million
iterations we're looking for any time
performance which is giving us a really
strong benchmark at 100 K the in the
original deepmind paper they needed over
a million
durations to get the algorithm to
converge and the sample efficiency
problem is one of the key reasons why
reinforcement learning algorithms are
not being used in the real world today
Co is the first model free reinforcement
learning pipeline with contrast of
learning to get state-of-the-art
performance on complex tasks kernel also
allows the deployment of reinforcement
learning in two domains where sample
efficiency is important remember to Like
comment and subscribe and we will see
you back next week so so welcome folks
we've got Aravind Srinivas on the show
today and aravindan was an intern at
deepmind last year and he's a member of
the technical staff at open AI he was a
visiting researcher at the Montreal
Institute of learning and algorithms and
he's currently completing his PhD at
Berkeley he's got a dual degree at BS
and an MS in electrical engineering from
the Indian Institute of Technology from
Madras and we're really really excited
about having
aravindh on the show because Aravind's
really really interested in unsupervised
learning and arab in recently released a
paper which is getting loads and loads
of traction in the community at the
moment called curl Arab in would you
like to introduce your paper sure so we
just released the spiracle curl contrast
the unsupervised representations for
reinforcement learning so the idea there
is to use this very recently popular
form of cell for unsupervised learning
contrasted learning to be a day
efficient on the reinforcement learning
tasks this is pretty much inspired from
my work at deep mind where we actually
improve the data efficiency of
supervised learning systems using
contrast to learning in this paper
called data efficient image recognition
from CPC where basically we showed
results that you can be 50% to 80%
inefficient on regular supervised
learning on I wish that if you do
training on the unlabeled data and then
finally into the label data so the
inefficiency is super like it's the most
important goal right now because we all
know that deep learning or reversible
learning works when you have a lot of
label data or a lot of agent experiences
so the thing that almost everybody is
interested in right now is to how can we
create systems that are as as good in
terms of performance it can learn with
10x or 100x fewer samples right so and
and people believe that self or
unsupervised learning is tomato way to
do that because you learn a lot more
about your data that way for instance if
you are just trying to optimize the
reward function or just predicted labels
you don't learn as much about the data
you have as compared to like actually
try and understand or make sense of what
is present in your offices or Rob
observations so indeed efficiency is
even more critical in control or
reinforcement learning setups because we
want the agents to actually operate in
real time in the real world at some
point we want our as the world view also
for that we need our of the work fast
that's the most important thing and so
we thought like we could just apply this
contrast learning there and since my
time at deep my in contrast to learning
is also gone through a lot of changes we
were working with the CPC framework
thinks God lost simpler recently with
timing he's Boco paper momento
contrasted learning and the paper from
Google in Toronto tink Chen and Geoff
Hinton on simply er where the idea of
extracting practice from an image was
was ignored and then people started
working with just instance level
discrimination tasks that made
implementation a lot simpler and
it's much more elegant and and also
produces better numbers so so we took
that from a progressive learning and
added it as an auxilary task in
reinforcement learning and this means
out the sample efficiency of real person
learning system significantly and not
only that is extremely simple to
implement like in the past they're being
works that we used try to use auxiliary
tasks the speed-up reinforcement
learning setups that look like there's
this paper called deep mind three to
four years ago called Rio unsupervised
learning unsupervised on scenario asked
for a maxi and word which is actually
one of the first papers to show some
kind of sample efficiency gains on rel
where they try to predict things like
the future frame in the task but with
that involves using an autoencoder like
setup you're trying to actually take the
pixels or patches or like the frame it
is a value function task it's still
pretty complicated we thought that you
know all these reconstruction based
tasks can be done away with giving all
the latest parameters in contrast
learning and it turned out to be true
and even though it's like better than
the existing methods the most important
thing is is vastly simpler so it's like
few lines of extra code and it can be
plugged in placed into anything any any
any any airline so that was the major
motivation for me to this work that's
really really cool I mean there there
are so many at would you know we're
holding so many doors I've been
simultaneously at the moment so you
might have to close one at a time but
just to come back to the reinforcement
learning part first you said that
there's a kind of crisis in
reinforcement learning at the moment you
know which is the sample efficiency
problem and when you finished your KO
paper you kind of said that it allows
deployments of
reinforcement learning in two domains
where sampled efficiency is important
because I think the original deepmind
paper had something like well it was in
the millions of iterations in order to
converge and one of the things that
surprised me at the time is the decline
paper didn't include the raw physical
states version it didn't show what the
difference was from you know using the
raw physical features and and and the
pixels I should say I should clarify
that the original unreal paper was
published the deep mind-control
benchmarks did not exist so that
benchmark was created by them just a
couple years ago i think so i think they
focused on experiments in deep mind lab
which is the navigation task and atari
so so that that way i wouldn't say they
didn't intentionally show it or
something and i think people still
believe in it is like learning for 200
million steps you look at those that
paper they mainly focus on getting
better numbers as the synthetic
performance rather than actually
focusing on learning and hundred
thousand steps to comparing having
access granted state but since you've
had so success there i think we are now
slowly veering towards like the faster
learning Ben Schwartz sorry Connor yeah
I had a question about the 100000
interaction step kind of metric for
bench boring bits running date
efficiency with these reinforced
learning algorithms because when you
have like a world model with the
variational auto encoder that samples
some inputs and then learns how to
reconstruct the space and then you can
sample trajectories in your world model
like so I don't think the interact
interaction step is a fair comparison
when you have something like curl Buzz
only model free no world model every
interaction is in the real world
compared with like planet and dreamer
where they can learn in the Leighton
space so I think that kind of difference
between model-based and model free
reinforce learning makes the 100k
interaction step kind of metric a bit
odd to use so well I would say that the
model based methods are likely to be
like you would use wander Yi you would
expect them to be much better
samp efficiency but I would also say
that the and some level of complexity to
your TA pipeline like like the moment
you start dealing with things like
predicting the future in a latent space
you're changing the architecture bid and
you need to figure out how many steps
you want to predict into the future so
in spite of not doing that that's the
main thing in spite of not doing any of
that
we are still better than those methods
and so that means that once we add
things like time-based
models predicting the future we are
going to be even better right so and and
and so that's the main thing Emma and I
in spite of being more free it's getting
a lot lot better
mm-hmm one more question I had is about
these auxiliary tasks and where you're
the observation oh goes to Q through the
moment of contrast encoder and then it's
also being updated with the reinforced
learning gradients so if you added a
future predictive model as well say you
know predicting cue representations like
plein air dreamer it's not trying to
reconstruct the pixel space how
complicated is this multitask
optimization are each of these different
tasks that contrastive so supervised
learning the Q learning you know
software critic solved actor critic and
then the predictive future model are
they going to all just pull the
gradients in such different ways that it
becomes challenging to optimize the Q
good question so if you look at the
contrast to loss it's it's basically
like a classification task it is like a
classification loss and like if you look
at more course in cleaner you can
consider the task or something like I
have the anchor and I have a bunch of
images one is the true label the
positive and Resta negatives so that's
like a cake a class classification task
so because it's a classification tasks
the loss is much more well-behaved it's
the cross entropy loss is bounded by
behavior and it's it's it's not it's not
going to die
dominate your reinforcement learning
loss so it it could it plays nicely with
there are a loss on the other hand if
you're doing something like predicting
the future in latent space or in the
pixel space let's say you're doing
pixel space predictions you're you're
then actually having something like a
mean square error loss on the pixels and
there are so many bits to optimize there
if your pixel dimension is really high
like say you're actually operating in
like 84 84 then Dan loss starts to
dominate your reinforcement learning
loss and so you need to figure out the
right hyper parameter to balance that
objective with RL objective so if you
look at all these papers like soft as
some had a critic with or encoder or
like planner to dreamer you would notice
that there are some kind of hyper
parameters to control this to make sure
that the model still runs fast in our
paper we don't have that which is we
have like know how to parameter
controlling the two objectives they just
very neatly play with each other and I
think this is a property of contrast so
that doesn't exist with other models
similarly if you were to predict in the
latent space it's still going to be a
high dimensional prediction just because
you made it Layton doesn't mean that
you're actually having a much smaller
loss you because you would still deal
with continuous vectors and predicting
the future continuous vectors it's still
it depends on whatever model you use if
you use some kind of mixture density
network you would still have some
gaussian log that you've lost and it's
not it's not lower bounded at all so the
KO and Gaussian is not personal lower
bound word so so that's that's why using
so so at a general level the more loss
functions you have a look more like
supervised learning by supervised
learning I mean classification the
easier and easier and simpler your
likeness and and and and this contrast
the loss is once it's lost it is exactly
like supervised when you're creating
labels for free by creating these proxy
anger positive negative tasks and
therefore it is a thick blankets it's a
much better choice if you considered
multi objective optimization so I had
sorry I had I had a question about this
because if you think about yes it's true
that the classification loss is much
more easy but also there is much less
information in simply a a classification
into whatever positive and negative
anchors then there is from
reconstructing pixels so one would
assume that kind of reconstructing
pixels would give you a much at least
information 'le richer richer
representation right when you compare
the the contrast representation with the
reconstructive representation none of
them none of them have in mind the task
you're trying to solve right none of
them have this RL task in mind both are
completely unsupervised how do you what
do you think is the the matter even
though that basically you have much more
information in the reconstruction it
seems to be that the contrast
representation seems to be much more
effective that's a great question I
think the best way to think about it is
what is the most useful information it's
not about the number of bits because not
all bits are created equal so if you
look at the mutual Xavier at Ari about
Yoko what do you care about is the agent
right there are so many things in the
background that you like for instance if
you looked at these walker or cheetah
there's all this background like the
floor and the background of the agent or
like or an Atari does these texture
patterns like these don't actually
matter because they're not gonna help
you solve the task better where is the
prediction task doesn't know that it's
just trying it's just going to try to
predict everything and this has always
been the biggest challenge in
unsupervised learning Nick how can we
get objectives that naturally focus on
the things that we care about without
actually knowing what we care about
because the training does not
necessarily have to know like what is it
a skier trying to perform I was a
downstream labels over ever but it
should still be able to learn only the
useful aspects of the world and I think
before contrast of learning we never had
an answer to that and I'm not saying we
have nailed the problem it depends on
how far contrasted learning can go but
it it definitely seems like contrasted
learning is figured out a great solution
to this problem if you look at like for
instance look at simply focusing on two
different data augmentations of a dog
and you're trying to associate them just
as a classification task so if you're
trying to perform this task
how are you go about it like you would
immediately say that hey these legs look
like it's it's it's belongs to the same
creature so then you start focusing on
the legs or like let's say the random
crap covered the face of the dog but now
the body then you would focus on oh like
you know this this fact this looks like
a dog's face and you you you start
looking at these important details
sizeable details whereas if you just ran
a very encoder of dogs you're looking at
you're trying to focus on everything
when the background the dog the sky all
these pixels are as important as the
pixels of the dog's face right so the
model doesn't know like what focus on so
and it's a great it's a it's a great
outcome of contrasted learning I would
say it's been the grand role
unsupervised learning to focus on the
most important aspects and some learning
seems to be able to do that mean
the follow is it may be fair to say that
let's say the magic isn't so much in the
fact that we do this contrast of
learning but the magic is that we are
with contrast of learning we're able to
just come up with much better objectives
right but it's still we still need to it
still seems to be important that you
know we actually do this cropping and
and things like this like if our tasks
we can just plug in any old tasks like
it still seems to be very important what
the task is is that fair to say unless
you provide those kind of fundamental in
variances in your data just in your data
to the model or the agent it's very hard
to be sample efficient right so look at
supervised learning that's the only
thing that's majorly worked in in in in
in in deep learning and and so you are
using all these ideas they're like
random crop is the most important aid
augmentation in Houston or even like
cocoa detection no segmentation and then
boost the performance of systems where
vast margin so it's it super so how do
you do that without labels is the
question and so I suppose learning lets
you do that through this fault learning
contrast learning well but you're right
like we need to be it's very domain
dependent for images it's fine but let's
say you moved something like language
it's not clear what kind of data are
conditions to use there see you would
have to do things like predicting the
future which is more like CPC framework
so so instance discrimination is
somewhat limited to like feelings is and
so so here right like in performance in
general it's always like if you want
really good numbers with
much smaller model like a model that
just looks really fast you need to make
it more more intimation to it
Tim had made a joke before we started
recording about having a paper and then
taking a different paragraphs out and
telling if it's in the same paper so
kind of an idea of how you would
generalize like your contrast of loss
into the text data domain so like I'm
just curious about the construction of
these positive negative pairs and kind
of like so let's say you form the
positive pairs with like t minus 1 and t
plus 1 are the positive pairs of t and
then every other frame is negative like
how do you see the role of data
augmentation compared to maybe like a
time way of constructing the positive
negative pairs yeah that's a great
question so I think you need to still
use data augmentation if you look at our
CPC paper from deep line the data
deficient image recognition CPC we do
time based or space based predictions
like we take the patch at the top row
and predict the bottom bottom rows
patches but we still use a lot of the
documentation there so you need to do
both and it's counter-terror you be like
you if I'm just predicting the future or
like I'm just predicting spatially
adjacent things why should i do relevant
asians it's a bit hard to understand
it's more like you know you're
maximizing the mutual information
between these two entities in some sense
and to do that efficiently you need to
use a lot of organizations or else the
information shared is too high and the
model starts cheating but potentially if
you want to extend curves something like
time base curl where you're lifting from
t minus 1 to T or T plus 1 and you're
trying to like say this is the right T
plus 1 for this t minus 1 and everything
else is fake you would still have to use
the augmentations together the
state-of-the-art performance but even if
you don't use data validation I would
expect something useful happen there
that's really interesting I mean they
might be worth saying
one of the interesting things about
reinforcement learning is that there the
iid assumption isn't true because you
know there's a strong correlation
between the successive frames but again
there are so many different topics that
we're touching on here it's quite hard
for me to kind of bring a narrative
together because I'm slightly worried
there and so some of our listeners might
not be experts in machine learning so we
should provide a little bit of context I
mean one thing I'm interested in is is
this concept as you were saying that
these augmentations can allow you to
learn global and local features and
we're actually moving towards this this
situation now where unsupervised
representations can actually be even
better than supervised representations
so I want to explore that but I also
want to cover the history a little bit
about contrasted learning because I
think the key idea is that
distinguishing between things is
actually more important than having the
kind of representation of how to create
something from scratch and that the
there's a few different concepts here so
there's this idea of transfer learning
there's this idea of self supervision
there's this idea of data augmentation
and coming up with you know semantically
relevant tasks that allow you to sorry
that's my time stop I've said a
30-minute time there so that then okay
shut up I'm sorry I'm so sorry about
that
okay so we'll cut that doubt but I think
the the first instance of transfer
learning and self supervision that was
super interesting for me was the skip
ground model by mikhalev and though
there was a similar thing right because
the first version of it actually had a
soft max output space across the entire
vocabulary and it was kind of
computationally intractable and then
they did this wonderful idea they said
you know let let's have a kind of
contrasted loss and what they did was
they they came up with I'd only used the
word augmentation but they'd you know
they were saying does this word belong
in the context of the other word and the
model was learning a kind of semantic
equivalence or linguistic equivalence as
a basis of how close the words are but
at this point we weren't really undoing
perturbations and then there was a
similar concept with the face net paper
so that had a contrastive loss and that
was using the the margin based triplet
loss and there is a kind of negative
sampling strategy where you would make
them
model converge quicker if you could find
you know you had like an anchor and a
positive and a negative and you would
try and find an anchor and a positive
which was as dissimilar as possible you
know to make that the model learn so
there are so many examples of this and
then sim SIA Lara I kind of see as being
the the canonical example in envision I
mean there was also deep info max by
Devin yelman and a few other similar
papers but we're really starting to see
this hitting the the computer vision
world out yeah that's right yeah it's a
great point you made with work back the
I would say contrast the predictive
coding CDC is basically word to that
done for images bear in store words you
look at passions in an image and you are
trying to predict the surrounding past
from your given patch or like top
patches from the bottom bottom from the
top left to right right to the different
directions so for me was like oh oh damn
like is working on images as well and
that was like the most exciting thing to
me about contrast learning for images
it's like this is good to make is kind
of coming back in a different form
though in NLP people have moved beyond
word to back now like like Bert is
really the way to go for NLP compared to
you know like skip gram or XQ talks kind
of models computer vision I think you
can do that you can't do things like
Bert because it's it's too hard to
predict the pixels you may be able to do
something you may be able to have some
kind of reasonable reasonably good
looking results
I'm sure people will do that I think
it's hard to be contrasted at yet too
specific with your question the best way
to understand the success in these
contrasting models is like thinking
about it in the same context as were
doing and what about this concept that
and because I think that one of the
major things in
in CLR was that for the first time even
on imagenet for example it was producing
state-of-the-art results so could you
give us some intuition on why that might
be so so sim clear so there are like
multiple bank marks for Super
unsupervised retraining on on on on
images so the one thing is linear
classification which is you take your
model you freeze the features and you
put a linear classifier on top and you
see how good that classifier performs
compared to just regular supervised
learning it's more of an academic test
it does not have much practical value
except the fact that you could
potentially just store features instead
of images if you are like a company like
Facebook or Google a lot of image data
and you can refer to store each of them
so so that's one year ago the best
number of on that metric was 55% and
right now it's 77% so just a matter of
here
it has gone up by 22 percent when I
started my internship element we were
like okay let's let's just get 70
percent that would be amazing and we
will get there like when we released
contrasting predictive coding version do
paper in December we got to 71 percent
and then simply took it to a whole new
level moku is taken again into a whole
new level now by even using even smaller
architectures and getting there so
that's one metric the other metric is if
you if you do this free training can you
do those features can you do transfer
learning so you can take you can just
except avoid learning you can take the
backbone that you use in free training
and put it in a downstream tasks like
object detection and that's that's
there's been a test called the Pascal
Pascal walked is it
very used it's not a lot of legal data
there so you do need a good backbone to
get good numbers there and there has
been a general consensus to through the
last few months that self supervisory
training was never as good as
supervisory training it was always like
few percentage points worse so if you
look at this Berkeley professors website
Alyosha
if roasts have said he has it he has a
thing called the chill out of it
that he made with this computer vision
pioneer Jitendra Malek that sound
supervisory training could never equal
or surpass supervised free training
which is you you just take all the
emission and labels you train a
classifier and you use that as impactful
compared to you unsupervised filtering
no labels and use that as a backbone
both are compared on the same Pascal
Pascal test and to to moco and CPC
version to this was never like the
consumer was preparing was always worse
and then finally as supervisory training
got better than supervised free training
on this on this benchmark so now that
was like the first signs of life on the
transfer getting set up and on the third
thing is fine-tuning to the same dataset
which is okay like let's say you have
all the labels let's say you're a
startup you have like a lot of label
data why would I care that you like to
equal you caster and it turns out that
you do pre training and then you find
you that model to for classifying so you
have a mission at you have all the
labels but ignore the labels first due
to unsupervised be training and then
take that and find you to all the
vehicle data you have so it turns out
that surpasses supervised learning now
so if you look at our CPC version to
paper on when you have the 100% of the
labels that you have all the labels all
the one milling labels you get 83.2% of
one accuracy
to 80% off on accuracy of regular
supervised learning just by doing the
pre train please find yourself what what
happens can you can you combine that
sorry can you combine that with your
loss I mean sorry for interrupting here
you could potentially combine the two
losses and and that's a good idea we we
didn't try that but I would imagine that
to work reasonably well yeah people
trying it like nothing has been really
published yet in terms of a good number
but pre-trained is fine to you seems
like a better thing to do because you
could imagine potentially having 100x
more unlabeled data than label data
right so as a quick question could you
give us any intuition on which variables
are important here because I could just
be cynical and say oh it's the amounts
of data that's important because with
these auxiliary tasks you can generate a
seemingly infinite amount of data as we
do in these language models I mean
Microsoft just released project cheering
which is a language model that has it's
in the billions of parameters and I know
that and Jannik is a bit cynical because
you can ask it you know who won the
second world war and when was the second
world war over and if you don't know
whether it's memorizing it or not but
but when you have supervised problems
you can have many many annotations and
many different types of label and on
imagenet for example there there might
be a phenomenon that exists in all of
the images that was not accounted for
with a label so surely that would not be
learned by the machine learning model
but it would be learned if he did an
unsupervised task so what what's
important and what's not important so
most important things to train for a
really long time Sam supervised learning
if you look at any of these papers
just take a look at simply er the Train
4000 a box for all the data efficiency
gains on one percent 10% emission and so
that's a crazy long time to train
supervised learning is usually trained
for ninety bucks so you could ask like
hey what if I do supervised learning
4,000 a box - you wouldn't get the same
kind of gains you get from unsupervised
retraining we like a song being
published but we've actually tried such
things so so that means that
unsupervised free training is the like
make it because it learns a lot more
about your data set it needs more than a
train but because it trains so
sufficiently long time it ends up
creating more value for you yes another
trend I saw on the sim clear paper is
that as you scale up the width
multiplier you get huge gains like the
76 point
76 percent accuracy that's the for x
width x if you go down to the ResNet 50
you know even moco 2 is like 71 so
scaling up the size of the model is I
think that was one of the big key ideas
and some clear is that as you scale the
model size they really benefit from
doing that so my question then is if
you're trying to apply that idea into
reinforcement learning is how big of a
bottleneck would it be to take a ResNet
50 with a 4x width multiplied and be
constantly using that to map from the
observation just into the latent
representation then it goes to the cue
function like that another recent paper
is like thinking while moving that's
like the hot paper now is trying to get
a wrap around this pipeline where you
have to like see it think act you know
like how big of a like reinforcement
learning agents they seem to need to be
able to go from observation to
representation like way faster so do you
think some kind of neural architecture
search like how do you think these big
models can be adapted for reinforcement
learning or is that really important at
all
yeah that's a great question so let me
let me separate into two parts the first
part that you mentioned that width is so
useful and supervised by training on
images that that's something I was gonna
say as well I like like to the earlier
question and what is what is the most
important thing like like training
really long was one important thing
the other important thing was making the
models wider or like deeper or like both
and and and and and even CPC were should
do have shows that like using pretty big
residences giving you a lot of games and
and simply are again the same thing them
making the model for X wider helps you a
lot this is not true in supervised
learning and supervised learning you
made the models deeper a wider you would
get gains but you wouldn't see the same
kind of gains that you see in Salesforce
behind so so the second thing is what
happens if you apply similar ideas to RL
I think the main problem in
reinforcement learning is the
environments are not sufficiently
diverse and complicated enough right now
for these large models to really matter
like look at image net there are like
million images there's so much to learn
about the world sure it's inefficient
right now you see every image like
thousand times at least to learn
something but if you look at Atari the
environments are sufficiently simple
like that even if you learn all the
possible authority you're not actually
gonna ask which diversity is like
million labels on emission and
unsupervised training can even be
applied to the even bigger data sets
that means to graph so unless we have
that kind of visual diversity that we
see in the data set like a missionary or
Instagram for reinforcement learning I
wouldn't imagine these kind of model
scaling to actually matter over there
but one kind of scaling that really
helps in our rel is scaling the box like
this like that's been applied in
StarCraft and Buddha where you just
train for several days on large backside
like extremely large amount of samples
so Starcraft used a lot of data but it's
a different kind of data like in the
sense that it's not actually images or
pixels it's more structured information
like a lot of you know you're actually
operating in the entity level there so
but Starcraft is one example a lot of
diversity I would say unless you collect
a lot of like navigation grasping
manipulation video games like something
like you know millions of these things
it's very unlikely for large models to
really matter and we in level another
another kind of key idea in the paper is
that it's doing the continuous control
from only pixel inputs and none of these
physical state so and I think a physical
state I think of say like the bipedal
walking agent and open AI gym where you
have like the angular velocity on the
hip and knee joints could you talk a
little bit about why it's important to
be able to do control with only pixel
inputs and like why we would want to get
away from physical state inputs because
it doesn't seem to me like it would
necessarily be so hard to put like four
sensors on the robot to have that
additional information that's a great
question so why would it be very
important
it's important because potentially you
would learn you could learn
absolu and experiences from various
different robots and various different
tasks and you would want to have a
simple universal input for everything
right so let's say there are like
hundred robots different kind of robots
learning in different worlds different
environments doing different tasks and
you all you have is a camera that
records everything you could still
recall the sensorimotor information but
it's much easier to learn one visual
representation across all these
different setups and that needs you to
learn from rafacz it's like there's no
other way and secondly it is it is
objectively true that convolutional
neural nets are easier to work with than
MLPs
so if you look at our numbers on some of
the benchmarks the pixel base
curl method actually outperforms even
the state based on some environments so
it's actually no upper bounded by the
steel state based ro in principle we can
actually be even better so those are the
two main reasons like you know like
state base is something you design
yourself like you say hey okay like you
know these are the variables that matter
and sometimes that plays a big role for
instance if you're doing something like
a reach or task if you give relative
distances instead of an zero distances
or if you incident joint angles if you
sinusoids of the triangles your Sam
position C is very better because it m
up easier like finicky and they just
work if you re parameterize your inputs
in a very format but you don't want to
be doing this kind of domain engineering
for every new task if you just provide
the pixels the model is going to figure
out anyway all the information is there
so the eye I think in principle when it
starts working really well
we long move to that format have you
have you ever have you ever tried to
recover these true state variables from
this the representation that you learn
for something like you know a walker or
so we're pretty sure that the joints and
so on are the correct variables two to
two feet to the RL algorithm right so
have you could you determine how much
information about that like you made
maybe you predict them from your state
have you ever tried something like this
and you can conclude yes it is actually
learning the correct variables or
surprisingly no it's learning something
completely different but still works
that's a great question so we actually
have an ablation in the paper where we
show that we can actually predict the
information from the from the pixels on
the easier environments but on the
harder environments like half cheetah
you're not actually able to predict that
that's one environment where I would say
curls is still not there yet in terms of
matching this state-based state based RL
method and that basically means like you
know their system some model information
in the states that you just can't
recover from the pixels are
representations and potentially
hampering the performance when when when
compared to state based methods
considered like something that cannot be
solved it's more likely to need a little
more engineering in terms of how you
construct the architecture that's a
great question like if you if you are
able to recover the information that you
fundamentally consider important like
velocity or positions or suppose it
means that you have a good
representation just a couple of just
just a kind of riff on that just for a
tiny bit more because you were saying
that the CNS can actually produce even
better results than the state variables
and I mean CNN's are really interesting
because then they are part of the reason
why we have the
I mean all of the really deep neural
networks our CNN networks and it's
because they they have this kind of
structure trick and weight sharing and
regularization and they make deep
learning you know kind of tractable in
some sense so I just wondered whether
you had any intuition on what it is
about that the cnn's that actually could
improve because the other comment I
wanted to make was some on the results
sometimes you don't get state-of-the-art
results so that they're that they're not
as good and presumably that's because on
those particular games the the the
physical state was only partially
observable was that right yeah that's
exactly right
so regarding CNN's you're right like
it's just amazing it's the right kind of
indict advice that seems to work on
almost any modality create audio-video
sometimes text are L pixels images
everywhere so and and so in principle I
think it's gonna work in better than
state and the second thing is when a
state of the art everywhere like we are
worse than state based in some of the
other environments and on South enormous
we're actually not even able to learn
like humanoid robot where this is so
much state information that you get
based on dynamics first or second order
that that would just be really really
hard to get from a few frames that you
just get from the Foley agent like she
just feed in three frames it's really
hard but I don't see it as fundamentally
limitation it's more like a limitation
of the architectures we are using for
frame inputs small CNN this is a
limiting factor potentially more an
architecture that looks as a hundred
frames or something like that I don't
think it's going to be a problem yeah
because I was just having a look at the
original take my paper a while ago
because I they they do the four frame
stack and then they have several
convolutional layers and the interim
compilation or layers actually have an
even because I have more filters than
there were an input frame so it's almost
as if they fan out
on the time domain and then they have a
fully connected layer where the time
domain gets collapsed in but one
question I wanted to ask you was was
about what you see as being the
limitations of CN NS because as good as
they are for kind of you know
translational equivariance that they
fail in some respects you know they they
only support play in our manifolds they
don't learn to see other symmetries in
in data I mean one of the reasons why I
transform as models are so good arguably
is because they can model a kind of
hierarchical long term dependency
between tokens and images so yeah you
know do you see there being an evolution
of different encoders yeah that's a good
question so yeah so I think I think
CNN's are doing local processing and so
fundamentally they are going to be
limited by the amount of global message
passing that they can do you would need
to stack a lot of layers for the
information to propagate all the way
through and so the other thing is they
lack multiplicative interaction that
transformers have in transformer
whenever you're doing the key value pair
mechanism you know you're creating
higher-order interactions between your
inputs and so you're going to be it's
just fundamentally working better and so
how to combine this kind of local global
information processing is really the
biggest question right now I can't
actually click in language it's fine to
just keep making everything attend to
everything else that seems to work
really well but but you can't afford to
do such expensive computation and images
even if you could fit in like a 64 risks
per image into a transformer it's not
going to scale to like a one-hour video
right so obviously you need more
efficient architectures and how does how
to combine the information saying that
rows and simple is like something
everybody is thinking about and working
on but the idea of using self attention
in reinforcement learning
is still under explored and though there
are being some papers on it nothing has
really shown significant games so I
think I think that it's more like when
we have the right kind of environments
architectures to explore these things
will start actually working and in
control synapses well I think in other
architecture that's interesting for this
is like the self attention again where
they just kind of put itself attention
layer kind of interleave with the
convolutional feature maps and that's
also like how the big end model works so
might sort of what I was thinking about
now is the difference between like you
know these transformer models like the
reformer and you know the adaptive
attention span they're trying to figure
out how to get away from that like order
l squared
attention computation or whatever it is
like what is the dimensionality of an
intermediate image feature map compared
to like the query key matrix because I
know you usually attend to a sequence of
say 4096 tokens and then each token you
know probably has at least 128
dimensions so you've got a matrix of 496
by 128 compared to these images which is
like what 32 by 32 you know see 510 or
you know like our isn't it as similar
compare isn't it actually easier by that
sense so if you look at something like a
self attention can it only loves in the
South attention at like a at lower
resolution than the actual image so the
actual image that these self engine cans
are generating like begins there they
actually like 512 to like you bigger but
you can but that would be like fired
into a square toughness right you kind
of full suspension at that level so you
down sample using a few layers of
regular receiver convolution
architectures you get it to a lower
resolution at 64 64 and then you put in
surf attention there or even 32 by 32
doctor that's we can deal with that and
that seems to be like the current set up
right now for how do you solve tension
in images
it's like putting it at the top after a
few layers of conversations but that's
not necessarily the most efficient way
because you're still relying on some
kind of down sampling mechanisms and you
could lose information there are some
attempts at trying to use up tension all
the way in the models but the gains from
those models are still not significant
enough for first we start using them
like the when you do that the models
start getting really slow because we
these these these kernels amara either
optimizes conversations and so there's
no reason to start using them at all but
I would imagine that like more working
with on their architectures are like
really hard to like usually the best
architectures that can stand out are
like the results of multiple attempts in
different directions and then someone
figures out the right combination of
details to make like the wrestler or the
dense net kanemaru swing so that is it
exists for substitution plus convolution
yet
so um I want to come back to the
contrast of learning a bit and
especially what you said before which
which i think is an outrageous statement
that if I have a data set a labeled data
set and I pre train it without the
labels and then fine tune it that works
better than if I just use the labels
it's like the reason it is outrageous to
me is because for every for every one it
just doesn't make sense right
intuitively how can you have more
information and and end up with you on
the less performant place so that's why
I asked do you combine them but in in a
more general framework I kind of want to
ask I remember a time when when the the
best way to train an amnesty NN was to
do layer wise unsupervised autoencoder
pre-training right and that worked
better than using labels before we like
figured out bachelor-man and it seems
just kind of the the same pattern again
where it like this cannot possibly be
the end and the best right what what is
your your opinion on that like clearly
there's something up here
I I was I was interested in pretty much
the same question myself and I've been
trying to make supervised learning even
better by trying to add like a lot of
augmentation ops and making the mouth
wider training longer like all sorts of
tricks to be honest it's it's not easy
to ask this unsupervised free training
because fine-tuning numbers given if you
try to do all these tricks and I think
it's simply because the unsupervised
free training methods like like contrast
okay training they just learning a lot
more about the data then then just
regular supervised learning so terrible
to generalize better to the validation
set compared to just regular supervised
learning I'm not saying that the
training performance is better like if
you look at the training set accuracies
so like pre training is not supposed to
help you over there but you through new
validation says it's very likely to help
you not significant you're not saying
you get five percent gains but war to
channel you're definitely right and that
is significant of the regime's that we
operated like if you look at eighty
three to seven eighty one percent OHS
are really difficult regimes another
paper that is the noisy student paper
from from walkway so just by doing this
kind of like semi-supervised learning
with unlegal data terrible to get one or
two percent more than the
state-of-the-art regimes like 88 86 so I
think that's what it's doing it's
basically learning more about the data
and therefore it's unlikely this fine
school is ways to classify images and
and therefore it's likely the
generalized yeah I think that that might
be the best way to pay with intuition
about it because there's a kind of
generalization crisis in deep learning
you know the models don't really
generalize a tool
and this is the similar reason why
perhaps data augmentation work since
supervised classification models because
what you're doing is you're kind of your
your your your showing the same thing in
in slightly different perturbed ways and
then you're you're helping the model to
generalize slightly better only when
when you do it in this new modality
you're generating an auxilary task
without even needing the labels at all
yeah I think it's also like similar like
it's kind of like the same framework
it's just that the positive key is like
one zero zero zero you know rather than
the other representation of another
image so it's like in supervised
learning you're matching the positive
key which is this one hot class label
vector or maybe like a smoothed out
vector you know it actually does kind of
make sense to me that the representation
would then be more semantic in the
contrast of learning because you're just
kind of like pushing them into those
positive keys where they all match and
it doesn't matter like you know how
different one cat is from another cat as
long as they're in that positive key
space of one zero zero zero zero zero
zero for something like C for ten so by
the way this has been shown in multiple
papers like even if you look at the
appendix paper and bocoe the appendix
section they actually should I take the
P train image narrow Instagram MOCA
models and find unit to the same
supervised set up and they find like
0.5% more or like 0.7 percent more and
it's been shown in CPC and not sure if
Sinclair had resolved on this but I
would imagine it to work there so so I
think I think I think it's so so let's
just say that it may be outrageous in
some sense but not as outrageous as like
you know it was like a pac-10 in those
days when you need to do the a high
speed training because I think back then
supervised learning itself was not
working like you just couldn't train it
deep enough model directly on the
supervised objective now you know that's
like something you just take for granted
it's like just like you know the
big learning success story what what is
happening right now this that works but
if you care even more about the numbers
if you want even better performing model
retraining is going to be the way to do
it and that matters right like you may
think like oh whatever
how does it matter if you can want to
send more and imagenet think about it in
terms of the number of errors you make
per 100 images and number of times the
models served for inference I can have
big company like Facebook or Google it
just is a huge impact even for like
point five one percent improvement and
and similarly like in any other computer
vision application so I think I think
that that's that's how I think about it
it's more like it just helps you in
these final gains that he just needed a
lien and it's also need in the sense
that you can take it and put it in the
transfer learning is also better with a
patron backbone than supervised backbone
basically with an unsupervised retrain
backbone is better so that means like if
you wanna if you wanna improve arms
detection or semantic segmentation you
would rather do unsupervised retaining
them supervised patron so yeah well in
that same topic what do you think this
framework could be stronger if you've
initialized it with transfer learning
because it seems like it's a random
network at first it's but doing both
moco and key learning is that correct
yeah this curl seems to start from
scratch and then learn moco and the cue
learning from scratch do you think you
could take you know image net weights
and start off with that or you know this
pipeline that we're talking about and
these stats because these simulation
tasks and they'd look very different
from initial images
but that's an interesting idea but in
real robot learning like acting hatha
would be pretty interesting to track
they take take moco and put it in
grasping robots con net and see so some
people actually paper recently Google
brain on this leg taking pre trained
cocoa models excitation models and
putting it on the robot robot grasping
and scenes and much better much faster
learning so those are interesting things
to try when you move to the reverse
innings ok so I think Yan Laocoon said
in a couple of interviews recently that
he thinks that you know the next
frontier of machine learning is
unsupervised learning I mean I think
that's already here to be honest it's
the most important ticket in town and
it's being used in absolutely everywhere
but and so assuming that's a given I'm
also interested in your opinion about
the future of reinforcement learning and
its utility in industry yeah so I think
young laocoön has been saying it for
like five years now it's amazing that he
just has been pushing for this kind of
successful piece saying right now impact
in like 2016 even before like supervised
learning was as big as it is right now
so I mean I think he gives a wholesome
picture already which I really like
which is the cone cake or the lake now
so the intelligence was the cake
unsupervised would be the cake and
supervised would be the ice so I think
that's really what I believe into like
like if you look at curl like there's
lot more to learn from the contrast I
lost and the reward signal it doesn't
even have to be the state of the art
you know like when we had the record of
benchmarks when you have the right kind
of models these contrast models which is
going to learn a lot more and transfer
better centralize better learn faster so
that I just think that's that's the only
likely outcome it may be possible that
somebody improves regular supervised
model other bridges are like liquid
reward optimization models but the
unlikely to be useful in the long run so
this same kind of conclusion with that
happened right now for supervised
learning will also happen for our like
where you do some kind of retraining and
then fine tune and then you're better
off singes learning with forwards no
matter how much reversing oh yeah that's
what I like the most people can always
say like hey sure you get gains when you
don't have our labels but the true thing
is you can gains no matter how many
labels you have and that kind of success
should also happen in normal setting
like no matter how how many imitation
trajectories you have no matter how many
reward signals you get just because you
have a great cake it should be possible
to learn even better and I think the
first signs like the way I will go over
it is see if somebody can create a
large-scale imitation learning benchmark
and we can just go on and try this ideas
like pre train and just do supervised
learning
Makemake always look more like
supervised learning there unfortunately
the best place to try these ideas is
like self-driving which cannot be in
academic mentorship so it's best right
an industry where like you have a lot of
data of driving data you do one super a
training Chris accepting like video
contrast learning and then you fight
unit to like protect different things
like pedestrians or traffic signs or
whatever and also like the optimal
actions
that systems likely to be much better
than just doing supervised learning
sorry I just have to get it on the
record I was at the Facebook party in
Vancouver at nerves and they did have
the cake on the dessert buffet and I
think I have a picture of it just I
thought this was funny and I pretty sure
it was not intentional and yeah creation
for young for during word and I think
they have there's a cake for that
celebration so it's one of the things
that is true and also I'm pretty pretty
pretty inspiring Ashley because you you
it gets it gets a try I think it's
fundamentally true cool so I'm just sort
of slightly conscious of the time so um
could we finish off by just talking
about your journey into machine learning
I'm really interested to know how
someone like you could you know
obviously develop all of this expertise
and were you passionate about it from a
young age and what's your kind of
process now for reading papers what kind
of papers are you reading out you know
what what's what what's your method for
kind of that you know Dan ingesting
information so let's see I I started
doing machine learning maybe you're on
2016 like I was undergrad in IIT in
India it's one of the engineers the best
engineering colleges in India so you get
access to tech fix like whatever is best
possible in India and so the professor
who taught me machine learning in in in
in ID he he was he was a student of Andy
Bardot who's one of the considered as
one of the father
well so he doesn't speech team with him
and so he was working on our
reinforcement learning and so I actually
start wanted to do research with him and
so he he just told me to work on
reinforcement learning and that was the
same time that deep mind started
publishing all these deep our papers
like like DQ + e DQ + + D willing DQ and
all these all these kind of different
papers so I just mostly started off by
reading deep mind papers actually and
and also just trying to understand other
works in regular deep learning like like
like sequence sequence and potential
mechanics and all that so it takes a
long time actually the in additional
effort you need to put in to understand
the basics it's so high that actually
have no idea how long it took because
it's been ongoing process from 2016 so
then I I did some research on oral like
wrote some papers on deep RL very simple
papers not not anything fancy and under
that God mean admitted to Berkeley for
for PhD with Peter Peele
who's my adviser and he's he's one of
the world renown experts on D power and
robotics so so after that I started
working on like regular D parallelism
and then there were a few students in
his in his lab who were more interested
in unsupervised learning generative
models and so that's how we actually
start off working on it and we may
actually have an ongoing class on that
like it's been going on for a couple of
years now called deepen spreading from
Berkeley cs2 nine four one five so the
best Verrazano topic is to try to teach
it right so we we actually just learned
a lot of which are the models
so super winning just because we are
teaching and you can teach it unless you
know some thing so you learn it that way
you're forced to learn and also by
implementing all these models like
there's no easy way you just have to
keep trying to implement these models
yourself and then I also internships
like in my first year summer intern at
open air with John Schuhmann and then
we've done proximal policy optimization
algorithms with them and I also happen
is I got chance to see those are the
beginning days of unsupervised I would
say like the modern and supervised like
Alec Radford was making probably so
chickity one and so Ilya sutskever had a
huge influence on me in terms of
convincing the unsupervised so there you
go and that's when we actually start
taking more seriously and shifted from
regular mainstream oral and then I was
interested in this contrast ability
coding framework and the internal
Ironman denude and deepmind he's the
inventor of CCC and leave next week UVA
all these models so learned a lot from
Ashley he and we did the CPC version two
paper and after that like I've just been
continuing on this path like trying to
do more and that's pretty much it like
we we just been trying to I think right
now I'm just planning to work on
unsupervised learning in the near future
sorry tomorrow's unsupervised learning
like making sure it helps in supervised
2rl those frameworks okay any more
questions
Konev on Yannick well Aravind this has
been an absolute pleasure and an honor
thank you so much for joining us today
I mean you know obviously that there's
that the whole reddit community I'm sure
going to absolutely love this so yeah I
hope you come back and talk to us again
soon
I really really appreciate it thanks for
having me and uh it was great great
great car chatting about thank you thank
you